hi in this video we'll talk about tie
for delayed hypersensitivity reactions
now our immune system in case of
hypersensitivity is hyperactive and in
this delayed type 4 hypersensitivity it
is known as delayed because the
manifestations of this kind of
hypersensitivity takes days to develop
at least 48 hours to 72 hours
it requires to develop now unlike other
hypersensitive response which are mostly
antibody mediated these hypersensitivity
reaction the type 4 hypersensitivity
reaction is T cell dependent and no
antibodies are involved in this process
and among T cells the th1 population is
key player in this process apart from
that macrophages and dendritic cells are
involved in this hypersensitive reaction
we would take an example we would take
two examples and try to understand what
is the signs and mechanism behind the
type for hypersensitive response
now first cons before the concept of
type 4 hypersensitivity arise
Robert coach in 1900 in 1890 s has shown
that if we inject tuberculin inside the
skin of a patient and he would measure
the blister size after few days like
after 4-5 days and try to see how what
is the diameter or what is the radius of
this bump and what is the area of this
bump now if the patient has TB before
after injecting the toxin the bumped
size would grow that means the
manifestation of these kind of reaction
takes at least four or five days and
after four or five days if a bump is
seen on the skin in the hand that means
that patient was earlier infected by the
TB but how this process is happening was
not known at that time
but he named it the tuberculin reaction
several years later people figured out
the mechanism and we would use a
specific example the poison oak
dermatitis the poison oak drama died is
caused by poison ivy is also an example
of type 4 hypersensitivity so first time
when you get exposed towards poison ivy
what happens we would see so poison ivy
has one kind of specific antigen known
as uracil now this usual would go inside
but your assault is a heptane so it
cannot evoke immune response by itself
now Yuri shawl gets oxidized inside the
skin and the oxidized form of uracil
reacts with the skin proteins and forms
uracil adduct
compound now which is immuno genic
so it can evoke immune responses now
first of all this immuno genic substance
is involved by specific dendritic cells
or Langerhans cells that are sitting
under the skin so once they are
endocytosed they are broken down chewed
up and displayed onto the surface of
plus 2 MHC molecules now soon after that
some of the dendritic cell or the
Langerhans cells would migrate along the
blood stream towards a near nearby lymph
node and inside the lymph node it would
present the antigen to a T helper cell
now the T helper cell which would
recognize these antigens they undergo
specific signaling and as a result the
secret lot of il-12 and if you know that
that il-12
is one of the auto clean cytokines that
would allow differentiation of a naive
cd4 T self into a th one population and
has been seen in case of delayed type 4
hypersensitivity that one the one sub
population which is prevalent is th one
sub population so the night T cell
differentiates in
rapidly differentiates into th1 cells
and their number increases over time
apart from these cells macrophages and
dendritic cells were involved now let's
just see what happens
sex happens to the second exposure now
once there is a second exposure again
there is a antigen presenting towards
the T cell and the T cells would rapidly
now proliferate into a debate expressing
th1 cells
now these th1 cells would secrete
several cytokines and most of these
cytokines are proven flama Tory like
it'll loop in one interleukin 6 if'n
gamma etc and also it would secrete
several chemokines first of all it would
create a overall overall increase in
inflammation redness and pain and the
second response is they would attract
more macrophages and dendritic cells
into the site of contact so overall our
inflammatory response would be evoked
and more migration of the macrophages
would be happening now the peak of the
reaction occurs 48 hours after the first
exposure and pier by the name is the
delayed type 4 hypersensitivity because
the manifestation of this contact is
occurring at a later stage and taking
quite a lot of time so that is why it is
known as delayed type 4 hypersensitivity
if you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you